FRANÇOIS LEGAULT, chef,
Coalition avenir Québec
- Si on commence à aller
dire des Toyota Camry et des
fourgonnetmimimimiliales, on va
mettre des milliers de dollars
de taxes, c'est pas le temps
actuellement quand on voit
l'inflation.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
parole, Québec solidaire
- Il a parlé de Toyota Camry
puis il s'est trompé. Il a joué
avec la vérité, parce que
l'écrasante majorité
des fameuses Toyota Camry,
elles ne seront même pas
touchées.
- Est-ce que la taxe sur les
véhicules à essence de Québec
solidaire s'appliquerait aussi
largement que le laisse entendre
François Legault?
Non, 4 des 6 modèles de Toyota
Camry ne seraient pas touchés.
♪ ♪ ♪
La taxe de 15 % viserait
les véhicules qui émettent
plus de amamamammes de dioxyde
de carbone par kilomètre.
Uniquement deux modèles, qui
ont des moteurs 6 cylindres,
dépassent la limite etenenenent
donc taxés.
Le prix de vente d'un de ces
modèles est d'environ 37 000 $.
Avec la taxe de Québec
solidaire, il faudrait ajouter
5600 $. Si on additionne la TPS,
la TVQ et les autres frais qui
s'appliquent, la facture totale
grimperait à plus de 51 000$.
L'immense majorité des
fourgonnettes, des camionnettes
et des véhicules utilitaires
sports seraient aussi visés
par la taxe.
Parmi le top 10 des véhicules
les plus vendus au Québec
l'an dernier, trois modèles
seraient épargnés parce
leurs émissions polluantes sont
sous la limite établie
par Québec solidaire.
Trois autres le seraient
partiellement puisque certaines
version du modèle excède
le seuil et d'autres non.
Erererere modèles seraient
entièrement taxés :
Les camionnettes de la série F,
le GMC Sierra, le RAM et
le Chevrolet Silverado.
Québec solidaire affirme que
des exemptions de taxes seraient
accordées données aux familles
nombreuses et à ceux qui doivent
utiliser leucucucucule
pour travailler.
Le parti s'engage aussi
à remettre l'équivalent à 15 %
du prix de vente à ceux
qui achètent des véhicules
électrique